CJ stra is dominating the NFL he is
making it look so easy he is 4 to1
against teams with a winning record he
has beat the Jacksonville Jack Wars he's
beat the Steelers he just beat the
Bengals teams that you would think is so
dominant we cannot confuse this CJ stra
is a top 10 quarterback in the NFL right
now he should be in a conversation for
MVP he might just win it all be the
second player ever to win offensive
rookie and MVP in the same season tank D
was playing at a really Elite level dton
SCH playing at a really Elite level he
is making the players around him so much
better he cemented himself it shouldn't
even be a conversation he is making a
statement right
now